the whole shape surprised me
there are many cars in that building and
there are also
two employmatic cuts i will tell you
what construction authorities said about
the house
they said it's the tear or the eye of
the god
i mainly see a teardrop the eye of the
god
is the sun who comes all over the place
hello my name is george and welcome to
our home
[Music]
i live in iraqion we decide to buy this
ground because of the view
so we are entering the main living room
this room is the room of light you have
a lot of sunlight
in crete we are people who live with the
light
light is all over it's very aggressive
the curve in front of the house is
philosophically the resistance of the
concrete
to the sun since the house necessarily
would
face this radiant sun it should be more
receptive
it should be bent by the sun's cause
from east to west
[Music]
you will go to the kitchen where if you
have a good cook
you can prepare something fantastic to
eat because crete has a lovely
variety of very good food the living
room
is in between the cantilevered volume
and the volume of the base which acts
as a podium and hosts the sleeping
quarters
most of what is going on
in the house you cannot imagine that
from the outside
going up the staircase one enters the
guest room that is in contact with
two open air spaces the one
is evident on the facade it is its main
cut
the other one is completely hidden from
public view
it is a cut of the roof underneath which
one may find an opener bath
i wouldn't advise you to jump in it but
it's very nice to
cool your body in the very hot nights or
days
of the summer and we have a lot of them
the other part is also very interesting
because at that part you have the
tear of god
and that's the view
that's the head of zeus who is very
kindly
to us in crete so
now for the easy part i will take the
elevator to show you the rest of the
house
hello again so here we are entering
our main bedroom this is the master
bedroom
where we sleep we have two more for the
kids
so i'll show you my secret place in the
house
and my secret place it's very easy to
access because you can open the trap
and you just have to go downstairs
it's meant to be a place where it's
quiet
and i can rest fortunately enough
sometimes i can do that
let me show you last but not least
one other thing that
is one of my demands that i had for this
house
[Music]
so this is my playground for adults it's
meant
to put a car on it and to turn it around
so you don't need to maneuver here
[Music]
this is one of the most peculiar designs
that we have tried and
i had certain doubts about
not the architecture itself i was more
concerned
about its relation to the city
but then i said okay we have to try
i think that they essentially work
together
they get more alive in my eyes
because of each other that neighborhood
was
invigorated by this playful house
and this playful house is in a
sculptural dialogue with its neighbors